the in this hypergraph
the this sort of limiting structure when
you have a very big hypograph
you can think of as being just like you
know water seems continuous on a large
scale
so this hypergraph seems continuous on a
large scale one question is
you know how many dimensions of space
does it correspond to
so one question you can ask is if you
just got a bunch of points and they're
connected together
how do you deduce what effective
dimension of space
that bundle of points corresponds to and
that's that's pretty easy to explain so
basically if you say you've got a point
and you look at how many neighbors does
that point have okay imagine it's on a
square grid
then it'll have four neighbors go
another level out
how many neighbors do you get then what
you realize is as you go more and more
levels out as you
go more and more distance on the graph
out you're
you're capturing something which is
essentially a circle
in two dimensions so that you know the
the number of
the area of a circle is pi r squared so
the it's the number of
points that you get to goes up like the
distance you've gone squared
and in general in d dimensional space
it's
r to the power d it's the the number of
points you get to
if you go r steps on the graph grows
like
the number of steps you go to the power
of the dimension and that's a
that's a way you can estimate the
effective dimension of one of these
graphs
so what does that grow to so how does
the dimension grow because uh
i mean obviously the visual aspect of
these hyper grass
they're often visualized in three
dimensions right and then
there's a certain kind of structure
uh like you said there's the i mean a
circle the the sphere
uh there there's a planar aspect to it
uh
right to this graph to where it kind of
it
almost starts creating a surface like a
complicated surface but
so how does that connect to effective
dimension okay so
you can lay out the graph in such a way
that the that the points in the graph
that uh you know the points that are
neighbors on the graph
are neighbors as you lay them out and
you can do that in two dimensions
then it's going to approximate a
two-dimensional thing if you can't do
that in two dimensions if everything
would have to fold over a lot in two
dimensions
then it's not approximating a
two-dimensional thing maybe you can lay
it out in three dimensions
maybe you have to lay it out in five
dimensions to have it be the case that
it sort of smoothly lays out like that
you